who would you bet on in a fight Zucker
you on gotta go Elon cause I'm waiting
on my cyber trucks it's always submitted
for me athletes have pre-game rituals
too oh yeah it was just throw The Big
Tease for takeoff go get enough you
could have dinner with one athlete right
right you gotta be Michael Jordan I need
some shoes who is the MJ and who is the
LeBron of Brad me for show is Taylor
Swift taking over the world taking over
the world what's your walkout song if
you were in the NBA
Hotel live how about the 15 passenger
let's get it if you could have one
athlete Beyond one of your songs right
now who would it be Willis McGee right
there I need a feature from are you
gonna go see Oppenheimer or Barbie got
to I like Christopher Nolan everything
you do is crazy